uh it's my pleasure to introduce ozbert
bastani from the university of
pennsylvania
and he will talk about safe human
interactive control
via shielding okay so yeah why don't you
take it from here
okay yeah um thanks for the introduction
and thanks for
uh inviting me to give a talk here um
and yeah so today i'm going to be
talking about some of our recent work
on safe human interactive control and in
particular using
how we kind of use a game theoretic
formulation and enable safety within
this formulation
um so the work i'm talking about is
joint work with
jivana anala
yeah so the the problem that we're
studying is uh
um settings where robots where there's
interest in deploying
a robot in a place where they must
interact with humans
and this includes both cooperative
settings where robots
work with a human to accomplish a shared
goal
as well as non-cooperative settings
where the goals of the robots and humans
might be different
for example in self-driving cars which
is going to be a running example
throughout the talk
um the the robot car has to interact
with the um other human drivers on the
road and pedestrians and so on
um who have different goals than the
self-driving car
um but it's also not a zero-sun game
because they all have this
um you know they all have a kind of high
priority for not
causing an accident
and in this general setting
the key question is how do we model the
human and this is especially important
in
non-cooperative settings where we need
to
reason about the human's behavior
the behavior of a human might who might
have a different goal than
ourselves and kind of a very general
solution
is to model this interaction as a
two-player dynamic game
and yeah here i'm going to focus on the
two-player case but a lot of these ideas
extend naturally to multiplayer games
and just to kind of give an example to
illustrate
some of the challenges involved um so
here i'm showing
a inter a simulation where there's an
actual human interacting with the robot
using via keyboard input and basically
so the robot is shown in red and the
human is shown in blue
and their goals are both to try and
cross the intersection as quickly as
possible
but beyond that their first concern is
to avoid an accident
yeah and as you can see there's a pretty
complicated negotiation process that
happens at the intersection
where the human and the robot are trying
to
pass first um but simultaneously trying
to avoid this accident
and to achieve this kind of behavior the
robot has to be able to
um plan in a way that accounts for
how the human responds to their
behaviors and this is why we need game
theoretic formulations of the human's
actions
so just to dive right in i'm going to
start off describing how we formulate
the problem
so as i said we're going to formulate
this problem as a two-player dynamic
game
and basically what this means is we have
a dynamics model
f which is a function of the current
state
and both the robot state urt and the
the current sorry the robot uh control
input urt
as well as the human control input uht
and then each agent has um this utility
function which is a just a
a sum over the rewards that they accrue
over
some time horizon capital t
and each agent is trying to optimize
their utility function
taking into account the behaviors of the
other agent
and as i said earlier a kind of key
aspect of our approach is that we're
going to assume that the human is
behaving
somehow in a rational way in particular
we're going to assume that they're
acting according to a nash equilibrium
strategy
and um yeah so
there are there is a lot of and humans
don't always act
optimally and there's a lot of work on
kind of modeling how human behavior is
boundedly rational but i'm not going to
be talking about any of that today
so we're going to just assume that the
human is acting optimally and
i'll go into i'll say and we do have
some assumptions about
exactly what this means which i'll um
describe later
and kind of given this general framework
our goal is to construct a robot
controller
pi r which maps the current state xt to
a robot control input urt
and there are two kind of goals so first
we want the
controller to reach the goal as quickly
as possible
so this could just be a goal region and
then we want to reach the goal region
after some number of steps but we
simultaneously want to ensure safety
so we want to stay inside a safe region
x safe
for the entire horizon and as i said
before safety is really going to be the
first
priority here our goal is really to try
and construct a safe controller
so there are two kind of key challenges
in this setting
um the first is the computational
complexity of computing nash equilibrium
strategies
um and the second one and
possibly more importantly the second one
is that we don't actually know what the
human reward function is
in practice this is the reward function
rh
and without the human reward function of
course we can't possibly compute the
nash equilibrium strategy
so i'm going to give some background on
one approach to human interactive
control in this setting
um and there there has of course been a
lot of work but
um this work in particular uh provides a
game theoretic form provides and solves
a game theoretic formulation of the
problem
so basically the idea to solve these
challenges in this prior work
first they're going to reformulate the
dynamic game as a stackleberg game
which turns out to be significantly
easier to solve
and the second cha to address the second
challenge the unknown human reward
function
um their basic idea is to use a
technique called inverse reinforcement
learning to infer the human reward
function
from data
so just kind of in terms of
computational complexity
as i said they formulate the problem as
a stackleberg game
and in a stackelberg game unlike a
traditional two-player game
the agents are going to play
sequentially rather than simultaneously
so what this means is that the dynamics
are now decomposed into two parts
we're going to assume that the robot
moves first and then they're going to
move alternatingly after that
so the robot dynamics are fr
of the current state and urt
and once the robot has made its move
then the human is going to
observe the new state and they're going
to take action u h
t and response and then that's going to
get us the next state x t
plus one
uh and just to kind of give a visual
illustration of this
the idea is so the robot in red is going
to go first
then the human and then it's going to
come back to the robot and they're going
to continue
um playing alternatingly in this fashion
uh and this is an approximate it is an
approximation to the true
kind of system but intuitively if you
take the
time step to be small enough this should
be a pretty good approximation
of the original game
uh so that like i said the nice thing
about zachelberg games is that they're
easier to solve
and in particular for the finite state
and finite horizon setting
um we can actually generalize kind of
standard
dynamic programming algorithm or
backwards induction algorithms
to solve stackelberg games and um
yeah i've written the here i've shown
the rules for the robot
so u r t star here is the optimal policy
at time t
and it's a function of kind of the um
and because we're going backwards in
time when we solve this it's a function
of the future
cumulative reward of the robot j star rt
so that's the value function of the
robot
from time t as well as the human
optimal policy uht which is shown in red
here
and that's because the human is moving
after the robot so
the robot's policy on the current step
is a function of what the human
is going to do on the next step and we
can solve
yeah so this is the equations for the
robots
we also have the equations for the
humans which i'm showing here
and as you can see now that's a function
of the robot's policy on step t
plus one um and we can solve this
backwards in order to get
um the optimal solution for both the
human
a nash equilibrium solution for both the
human and the robot
and one nice property is that this
actually computes a sub game perfect
nash equilibrium
which is a useful thing to have
um so one caveat is that we're actually
in not in finite state spaces
so we have a continuous state space
because we're thinking about a dynamical
system
um which means that we're actually going
to have a we can't use backwards
induction directly to solve the game
and in this paper um in this prior work
basically what they propose doing
is um just using gradient descent
on both urt star so the robot
optimal sequence of actions as well as
the human optimal sequence of actions
and just running gradient descent on the
corresponding objectives in order to
solve this
and you can basically and the reason you
can do this is because you can write
down everything explicitly in terms of
maxes and mins over the future
actions um so the main challenge here is
computing the derivative of the arg max
and you can do this using implicit
differentiation
um i'm not going to go into details on
exactly how that works
um but it's it's a pretty standard
technique
okay so um that's their
the way they propose to solve the nash
equilibrium strategies
and the next thing that the second
challenge is how to deal with the human
reward function which
is unknown on priority
and like i said the basic idea they use
is to use inverse reinforcement learning
to infer the human reward function from
data
and i'm just at a very high level the
idea behind
inverse reinforcement learning is to try
and
select a reward function r which
best describes the given data so here d
is the data set of human demonstrations
so we just have the human play the game
a bunch of times and we observe
what their actions are pi of r is the
um the optimal policy for a candidate
reward function
r and l is a loss function that compares
the state action pairs generated using
policy pi
with the data set the human
demonstration data set d
so there are various instantiations of
inverse reinforcement learning depending
on the structure of your loss function
the policy class
and the m structure of the mdp um
i'm not going to go into details but
just kind of at a high level
as you can see this uh objective is
trying to select the reward
function such that the state action
distribution of the pi
pi of r most closely matches the
observed
um date action pairs d
so yeah in this paper they propose to
gather demonstrations of human
behavior and then use off-the-shelf
inverse reinforcement learning
algorithms to estimate the
human reward function so with the human
reward function and
their solution strategy you can now
compute
um nash equilibrium strategies to the
stackleberg game
so they're kind of so this is a they
show that this is a pretty effective
approach but there are some significant
shortcomings if you want
provable guarantees and the first
challenge is that
because they're using gradient descent
uh it's susceptible in general if the
value if the rewards and the value
function
are non-convex gradient descents is
going to be susceptible to local minima
so they're not guaranteed to find a nash
equilibrium
solution
yeah basically if you convert to local
minima then the human might be able to
take alternate actions than the ones
that you predict they'll take
and the second challenge is that the
human reward function
is um while they're using data to infer
it there isn't really
this is just a machine learning
algorithm and there's no guarantee that
the invert
inferred reward function is correct and
you can deal with the inaccuracies due
to noise
but in practice different humans will
have different reward functions
so even if you learn um what a reward
function using
a data set from some subset of humans it
might not
generalize to reward functions in other
settings or
with other human drivers and so on
so um therefore again we can't really
guarantee
that uh the if we can't guarantee that
the inferred reward function is corrupt
then the human might act differently and
we can't ensure safety
and our goal is um really to design
a robot controller that guarantees that
the
um the system is safe we are also going
to make a best attempt to reach the goal
but we're not going to provide any
guarantees in terms of this
and of course we can't make unqualified
guarantees of safety so we are going to
need to make some assumptions about the
human reward function
in order to be able to reason about what
the human is going to do
and our goal is to really minimize the
required assumption so we don't want to
assume that
um that you know that we have a
representative data set of human
behaviors or that the
algorithm finds a you know a good
approximation of the human reward
function
and then with these assumptions we want
to guarantee safety
so um so that was the background on kind
of the
existing approach formulating this
problem as a stackleberg game
the way we're going to approach the
problem is
a bit different so it's based on this
idea of shielding and next i'm going to
go into some detail about um
some background on um the general
shielding algorithm
so um shielding is kind of a and it has
other names in the literature
um but it's it's it's basically a
general um strategy
where we want to ensure we're given an
untrustworthy policy pie hat
um so pi hat might achieve good
performance
um but it it doesn't come with any
safety guarantees so um
and we're also given a backup policy pi
backup uh and pi backup might not might
perform quite poorly
um so we're but so it's not going to be
good at achieving the goal
but in contrast to pi hat we know that
it can safely bring the system to a stop
from some subset of sites which we
denote by
x recoverable and we refer to this
subset of states
as being the set of recoverable states
and um just to oh right so and
the basic strategy in the shielding
approach is to try and
override the use pi hat as often as
possible
but then override it as necessary using
the backup policy
in a way that guarantees safety
and so we're going to guarantee safety
but we also want to minimally override
pi hat to ensure good performance
and as i said before we're not going to
provide any performance guarantees here
so um just to formalize the
notion of recoverability um
yeah so i'm just going to give an
illustration so here is a
you know self-driving robot um that's
trying to avoid the
um obstacle shown on the right hand side
and in this case we're going to apply um
pi
backup and
we state is recoverable if in this case
the backup controller is basically just
going to hit the brakes
and try to bring the robot to a stop
without crashing into
the obstacle and in this case
x is recoverable since pi backup can
actually safely bring the robot to a
stop
so yeah that's the definition of
recoverability
and with that in mind the algorithm is
very simple
um so in shielding basically we're going
to
the algorithm is going to use the um
optimal policy pi hat if it it's
basically going to simulate the next
state
um under pi hat
to get x hat t plus one so this is um
it's a simulation of where the robot
will end up if it uses pi hat
and then it's going to check if x hat t
plus 1 is in the recoverable set
and if so then the algorithm is going to
use pi
hat and if not it's going to use pi
backup
and the reason this works is that this
algorithm maintains the following
invariant
if in the current step we're in the
recoverable set
then the in the next step we're going to
remain in the
set and um so
as long as we start in the recoverable
set by induction we're going to stay in
the recoverable set for the entire
horizon
and it's pretty easy to you know show
that this theorem
holds um so just to give a quick proof
um if if there are two cases um so
if the algorithm uses pi hat then the
robot
sorry then the theorem statement follows
by the red condition so it's
you know we've just simulated it and
checked that if we use pi hat it's going
to stay in the recoverable set so
by that check we're going to stay in the
recoverable set
um the second case is that we actually
end up using pi backup
then um in this case basically
we started in the we assumed that we
started in the recoverable set
uh and what this means is and by
definition of recoverability
using pi backup can safely bring the
system to a stop
um so basically the same must be true of
x t plus one since we
use the backup policy pi backup must
still be able to bring us the system
safely to a stop
so again the theorem holds and we stay
in the recoverable set
and this is enough to um kind of prove
that this algorithm ensures safety
aspect i have a question
sure how do you compute this set x
recoverable yeah so i'll say that in a
yeah i was just getting to that so the
challenge here is that the recoverable
set is hard to compute and
is often hard to compute in closed form
um and
there's actually a really simple
strategy which is just using model based
simulation to check
whether x is in the set um so kind of
just to illustrate this
uh we're we're first going to as before
simulate one step using
pi hat to get to x hat t plus one and
now we want to check if x hat t plus one
is in the recoverable set
all we're going to do is continue our
simulation using pi backup
and if pi backup can safely bring the
robot to a stop
then we know that x hat t plus one is in
the recoverable set
um so so we have so this property holds
um if there's an accident or if we don't
come to a stop
then we can then we're not in the
recoverable set
and with this check we can just proceed
as before
so if we find that we are in the
recoverable set
then we'll use pi hat otherwise we'll
use pi backup
so that's the basic idea between behind
model predictive shielding
importantly this does assume that we
have a full model
of the dynamics that we can simulate and
of course that's not going to be true in
the human interaction setting which is
the key challenge that we need to solve
because we need to somehow model the
human behavior
and so next i'm going to talk about how
we actually leverage the ideas from
shielding
in conjunction with some analysis of the
um
human strategy in order to
adapt shielding to the human interaction
setting
so just at a very high level we're not
going to be trying to compute a nash
equilibrium solution because
really without knowing the exact form of
the human
reward function there's no way that we
can
compute this nash equilibrium solution
instead our approach is going to be to
try and act
conservatively with respect to a
rational human
so we are going to we're basically going
to um
try and prove that whatever strategy we
take
as long as the human is acting
rationally then our
our strategy will ensure safety
and basically the key idea is that we're
going to
assume the key assumption we make is
that the human prioritizes safety
and what this means is that we don't
need to reason about the full
possible behavior of the human because
they're prioritizing safety we only need
to prove that there is some strategy
that human can take
to maintain safety and then as long as
we know that the human can maintain
safety given a candidate action
then if we take that action the human um
will act in a way that maintains safety
they might act differently than the
strategy we discover
but their actions will still kind of
guarantee safety
and this follows by our um kind of by
our rational assumption that the human
acts rational
um
um so before we continue we are
in this work we are actually working
with a
simplified version of the human model
and um basically rather than
um in the multi-step zackleberg game it
actually alternates back and forth
between the human and the robot
uh instead in this work we're actually
considering a one-step stackleberg game
so we're assuming that the robot takes
an action
and then the human takes an action in
response to the robot's action
but when the human is um deciding what
actions to take
they don't forecast and compute every
possible outcome that the robot is going
to do
instead they're just going to act
conservatively with respect
to the um some subset of possible robot
actions
and that's kind of denoted in this the
minimization shown in red on this slide
they're going to act conservatively with
respect to some subset
so i haven't yeah there's basically some
bounded set here of actions that they
consider and then they act robustly with
respect to that set
and this is a one-step stackover game so
the robot acts
and then the human acts and then that's
it
um so this is a pretty big
simplification
but it does make sense in practice
because just like the robot can't really
anticipate doesn't know the human reward
function the human
most likely doesn't know the robot
reward function either so it makes sense
that they'll act conservatively rather
than actually try to
reason about the full time horizon
but then our rationality assumption just
says that the human is acting optimally
according to this
maximum objective function shown above
so this is the
model of human behavior that we're going
to consider and then we want the robot
to act in a way
that is safe with respect to this model
okay so next i'm going to go into
details about some of the key
assumptions we made
make about um both the human reward
function
as well as the uh about the human
objective
and so just to kind of have it here um
this is the maximum objective
that the human is acting according to
and we're assuming that they actually
follow this strategy
um so the key challenge is that i i
guess there are three parts in this
uh that we don't know um first we don't
know what
actions the human considers that's the
part shown in blue
um second we don't know the conservative
set of robot actions that the human is
taking into account that's the
minimization shown in red
and finally we also don't know the human
reward function that's
that's implicit in the value function jh
so our first assumption is about the
reward function so the only thing we're
going to assume
is that the human prioritizes
avoiding unsafe states and basically
what we're going to say is that the
human reward function is minus infinity
for any unsafe state and we're not going
to make any other assumptions about the
structure of the human reward function
our second assumption is that there is
some
backup backup action for the robot on
denoted u-hat
r and this is a action that the robot
can use to come to a stop
and importantly we assume that the human
is going to act conservatively with
respect to this action
so whatever set of uh kind of actions
the human is considering in the
min in the objective u-hat r is going to
be
included in that subset
and uh just as a very simple example um
the robot might consider the robot
backup action might be to
basically apply the brakes and gradually
come to a stop so
you wouldn't want it to be slamming the
brakes because humans often don't
anticipate another agent slamming the
brakes but um at least if they break
gradually the humans should be able to
anticipate and respond to that
so um yeah that's kind of a canonical
example of a good robot backup action
and the final assumption is on the the
human back of action oh sorry the final
assumption is that we're given a set of
human backup actions
that the human can use to come to a stop
and the only thing we're going to assume
about this set
is that if the human's objective value
is minus infinity
so if in this kind of maximum objective
the optimal um uh
the optimal over the objective yeah the
maximum objective values minus infinity
over human actions uh
then basically that means that all human
actions
are have equal objective value basically
the human doesn't
have any idea how they can um maintain
something that doesn't lead to an unsafe
state
and we're going to assume that um the
human is going to take some action in
this set of backup actions when this
happens so they're not going to kind of
select
non-deterministically or arbitrarily
over the set of all possible actions
they're going to specifically choose an
action that can bring them to a stop
and again this
can be some kind of breaking action the
reason we consider a set instead of a
single action is that we're giving the
human leeway
to take different kinds of possible
actions so they might break at different
rates or they might
kind of steer as they're breaking and so
on
so just to kind of illustrate um
the possibilities here i've kind of
shown the
the reachable sets under um both the
robot backup action and the human
backup action set so if the robot is
hitting the brakes
gradually applying the brakes then it's
going to come to a stop after some
amount of time
um that's this red arrow here
where the hum the robot backup action is
you had r and
because the human um backup action is a
set
um you had h um they might theirs is
going to be a region instead of a single
trajectory
um they'll presumably come to a stop
somewhere in this region so the
width of the region is accounting for
the fact that they might apply some
steering angle
and the um they might also apply
different
deceleration rates here so they'll come
to a stop somewhere in this cone shape
okay so given these assumptions
uh next i'm going to go into some detail
about our algorithm
uh osborne short question
so this x unsafe or acts safe
yeah so both the human and the robot
know the same x safe so they have the
same perception of safety
uh yes that's right we're assuming that
um
yeah we're assuming that they're that's
a good point we're assuming that their
notion of safety is shared um and that
that is a
so i think in our examples this um the
shared safe set is going to be that they
don't want to have an accident um
but in general if the human is not if
the human basically there's some
state that the robot wants to avoid but
the human doesn't uh that does make the
problem more difficult because the human
might actively you can imagine then that
the human could even act adversarially
and try to drive the system into that
behavior so this is a pretty important
assumption
right right okay that's a good point
okay are there any other questions
before i
continue
um okay so yeah that's the
uh backup action sets so
um
just to write down the human model again
and so you can
we can refer back to it uh that's the
same policy as before
so uh and so as i said earlier our
algorithm is based on this notion of
shielding
and in the shielding framework kind of
the really critical thing is to define
the notion of recoverability
so and really it's going to be the same
notion as before so we're going to say a
state
x is recoverable um if using the robot
backup
policy in this case just this single
action you had
r um from x safely brings a system to a
stop
so importantly and so yeah so that
that's just this red trajectory that
i've shown before but importantly
in this case recoverability depends on
the unknown human policy
so the human is also going to be taking
some sequence of actions and whether or
not
the robot comes to a safe stop depends
on what actions the human
takes and we unlike before we
don't know this part of the environment
we don't know what policy the human is
using
so we can no longer simulate the system
in order to check if a given state x is
recoverable
and what we're going to do is leverage
our assumptions about the human behavior
to have they establish basically a proxy
for recoverability
and this proxy is basically going to say
that a state x is recoverable if the
system can safely come to a stop
um after if the robot takes its backup
action
for all possible human backup actions
so regardless of what the human does um
in this bounded action set you had h
the system will safely come to a stop
and
in this case if the human actions
in in this case that in this kind of toy
example i'm showing on the right hand
side
um regardless of what the assuming this
is the reachable set under
um u hat h then the
system is in fact safe uh recover sorry
the robot is in fact recoverable because
the human will safely come to a stop
the robot will safely come to a stop and
the two of them won't collide
okay um so one important thing to note
and uh just to emphasize is that the
human we're not
assuming that the human takes an action
in
this set uh so this isn't um
just a matter of being robust to some um
subset of possible human actions and
they real they might in fact and they do
take actions outside
of ua um this set um so for example they
might take the green action illustrated
on the right hand side
which is not in this set um so
but the point the kind of key thing that
we're leveraging here is that because
the human is acting rationally
this green action must be better than
any of the blue actions
and because the human is prioritizing
safety
therefore if all the blue actions are
safe then so is the green action
that's the kind of basic intuition
behind our strategy
so as long as we're in a recoverable
state we're going to be able to
um as long as we're in a recoverable
state we're going to be able to take
the uh we're going to be able to
maintain safety just like in the
shielding the original shielding
algorithm
so just to kind of hash that out in a
little more detail
so our algorithm proceeds in three steps
um the first step we're going to compute
the human backup region this is the
reachable set
using the human backup actions you have
h
and as i said this is not the reachable
set of the human it's only
and the human might actually drive
outside of this region
the second step is to compute the robot
backup trajectory
and following the shielding strategy
we're going to first take one step
using pi hat and then take multiple
steps
over some bounded horizon using u hat r
um and then basically we're just going
to check
um whether the these two actually two
things we're first going to check
whether
um these two regions overlap we're also
going to check to make sure that they
bring the system to a stop
um if so then we're going to use pi hat
which is the
kind of preferred policy um if we can't
guarantee safety then we're going to
switch to the backup action
you have r um so in this case because
the
two sets don't overlap we ensure safety
and if they do overlap
as illustrated here then we're going to
switch to the backup action
okay
so um yeah and
we yeah one thing one caveat is we
actually perform so i'm going to go into
a bit more detail on the each of these
steps so
one caveat is we actually perform steps
one and two simultaneously because when
we
when we kind of
roll out the system we need to roll out
the human and the robot simultaneously
so basically we want to compute the
reachable set under the back assuming
under the robot backup action you had r
and the human backup actions you had h
so we actually use abstract
interpretation to do this um
any kind of over approximation of the
dynamics will do
um but i'm going to kind of just for
concreteness i'm going to just assume
that we're given a
function on an over approximation of the
dynamics that operates on
our subsets of the state space and the
action space
so the key challenge of course is that
the u hat h
is a set of actions so we need to over
approximate the dynamics in order to
deal with that
and basically i'm going to assume given
a function capital f
delta for each agent delta either the
robot or the human
and this is going to take a subset of
states
a subset of actions for agent delta and
it's going to output a subset of states
and the key assumption is that it over
approximates the dynamics
so given a subset capital x and of
states and a subset capital u of actions
it's going to contain the dynamics
little f delta of x u for every x and
big x and
every u and big u um so as long as you
have this then you have
um an over approximation of the
reachable set
under um actions big x and big u
uh sorry states big x and actions big e
and we're just going to apply this um
over approximation um so first we're
going to apply it to the
uh kind of in the initial state we're
given that's just the singleton set
x and for the first step we're going to
assume that the
robot is going to use pi hat and the
human will use
their backup actions so that's going to
get us to the next state x2
and then from there on out we're going
to assume that the robot switches to the
backup
policy the backup action you had r and
the humans going to continue to use
their backup connection
okay so just to kind of illustrate um so
after one step
we're going to use pi hat and
um um after the first step then we're
going to switch to using u-hat r for the
robot
and we're going to expand the reachable
set for the human and
roll out the robot trajectory at the
same time
and yeah as i said the formal way we do
this is using an abstract interpretation
framework it's a pretty standard
technique and i won't go into details
about exactly how that works
so once we've computed the sequence of
reachable
states of the system under these two
action sets
um now the net the third step is to
kind of check the recoverability problem
uh property
so first we want to check whether the
system is safe for the entire horizon
and we also want to check whether the
system comes to a stop
so those are the kind of two key
properties and
um the to check safety it's
we just need to check to ensure that the
reachable set big
xt on every step is contained in the
safe set
for every step t and to check that the
system comes to a stop
we just need to check that on the final
step we come to a set of equilibrium
states where the system is at rest
and again these are also checked using
the abstract interpretation framework
which i'm not going to go into details
about
so if both of these checks pass then
we're going to use
the um the robot the
the the optimal policy pi hat otherwise
if either of the checks fails then we're
going to switch to the
backup action okay so that's our
algorithm
um uh basically just to summarize we're
going to
roll out the system and perform these
checks and
um next i'm going to talk about the
theoretical guarantees that we
prove for this algorithm
um and
so first we're going to make a number of
assumptions which i've already alluded
to earlier
we're going to assume that the human
follows this model of their behavior
and we're also going to make the
assumptions one two and three i
described on a previous slide
and finally i'm kind of similarly with
the
shielding approach we have to assume
that we start from a recoverable state
so we're going to just assume that the
human and robot are at rest
at the initial state x1 so we're in an
equilibrium state
then our theorem just says that we
ensure that the robot
is that the system remains safe for the
entire time horizon
and um yeah i'm going to sketch the
proof the high level is going to follow
the high level structure is the same as
the shielding
the proof for the shielding algorithm
and i'll go into a bit of detail in each
of these cases
but the basic strategy is just that we
use induction we proved by induction
that xt is in the recoverable set for
each
t and because recoverable states are by
definition safe this will establish the
property and the base case just follows
by assumption
um yeah i guess it's obvious that if the
human and robot are
at rest then we're in a recoverable
state um so
as before we have two cases that we need
to deal with the first case is that the
robot
uses the optimal policy pi hat and the
second case is that the robot switches
to the backup policy pi backup
and in this case it's just using the
robot backup action
okay so um
yeah so the first case in this case is
um the really
complicated one uh so um
this is the case where the robot uses
the
um the optimal policy pi hat and here um
again i've recalled the human model i've
in this case i've separated out the the
min portion of the maximum objective
and i just denoted that by j h tilde
so the and this is the objective that
the human is
maximizing and now we need to prove the
inductive
step um which is that if we start in the
recoverable set we remain in the
recoverable step
so the proof is basically goes as
follows so
since we're using the optimal policy by
the kind of check that our algorithm did
we know that the human backup action and
the robot backup trajectory
do not overlap because that's the check
that we did using abstract
interpretation
and they also bring the system safely to
a stop so first let's assume that the
robot
takes an action u uh uh
such that the objective value j tilde h
is
greater than negative infinity and then
kind of by assumption one uh we assume
that the
human um that the human accrues reward
minus infinity for any unsafe state
so if the cumulative value if the value
function is
greater than negative infinity then the
human then the system can't possibly
have reached an unsafe state
so the human action is safe for the
remainder of the horizon
and because the human is acting
conservatively
with respect to the robot backup action
so
we know that whatever action they took
if we
continue using uh the robot backup
action
in this red part then um we're going to
be kind of doing
something that they anticipated and
therefore we're actually going to
realize a
objective value that's greater than
minus infinity uh therefore we can
ensure safety
and the um therefore the system is
recoverable that's the
basic argument um so that's if the human
takes some
better action so this this is the case
where the human can take an action
that's outside of the backup region
because they found some action that was
better uh than those actions
the second case is that the objective
value is equal to minus infinity
and in this case it just follows by
assumption we assume that if the
objective value is equal to minus
infinity
then the human takes an action that is
in this
backup set um and
this time by our check which is two
points above the
the regions don't overlap so we know
that using the backup actions can bring
the system safely to a stop
and uh so so again um
in this case the system is going to be
safe
so um that's the proof in the case where
the robot uses the optimal policy pi hat
the the second case is um basically the
same as before if
instead the in the traditional shielding
proof if the robot uses pi backup again
we need to prove that
xt plus one is recoverable if we're
currently in the recoverable set
in this case the human backup region and
the robot backup trajectory might
overlap
but by definition if we use
pi backup from xt by definition of
recoverability
we're going to bring the system safely
to a stop
and since we in fact use pi backup the
same property must be true of xt
plus one um so x t plus one must also be
recoverable if we continue using the
backup policy from x t plus one
we must again safely bring the system to
a stop
um so this step follows as well
and uh together with the previous
case this proves the theorem so
basically we've proven that the
that the the shielding policy ensures
safety for the entire horizon
um so yeah finally just to wrap up i'm
going to give some
ex some results from the simulation
experiment
it's the same one i showed at the
beginning of the talk but we have
several a variety of different results
illustrating different properties of our
approach
so the experimental setup is that we
have this environment
where the car so it's basically a car
model with bicycle dynamics
so the control inputs are the
acceleration to apply and the steering
angle
and we have several different driving
tasks one of them was the crossing task
that i showed
we also have a highway merging task
where a robot is trying to
merge onto a highway with a human in the
current lane
as well as a left or unprotected left
turn task and i'll show examples of each
of these in a
minute so here for the robot
we used our approach in conjunction with
an aggressive
controller that drives straight to the
goal so this aggressive controller is
the optimal policy pi hat
and we basically used our shielding
approach in conjunction with this
aggressive controller
in particular this aggressive controller
is going to completely ignore the human
and just so if if there's a human there
and they don't move out of the way it's
just going to drive straight through
them
but the key idea is that this policy is
going to try to get to the goal as
quickly as possible
and we're going to fully rely on our
approach um the shielding algorithm to
ensure safety
and i i will also show one simulation
with a model predictive control baseline
um it's a pretty standard mpc it's
actually going to forecast
the human um trajectory assuming that
they
use a constant velocity input and then
it's going to
um compute a plan that avoids the human
under this assumption uh and it
basically uses cross entropy method
optimization to do this
i'm not gonna the details aren't that
important
um finally we compared about simulated
humans using the social forces model
which is a standard model of kind of
crowd behavior
um as well as more importantly we
also have some a lot of experiments with
real humans who are interacting with the
simulation via keyboard input
um yeah so i'll show results on both of
these
so um yeah finally just to kind of for
our approach we have some
a couple of parameters i need to
describe um and they're basically the
same
ones i described earlier and i see so
the first we need to specify the robot
backup action you had
r and basically the robot backup action
is going to
be to break at a given deceleration rate
minus ar so they're going to accelerate
at a negative
rate um and the steering angle here
actually this is supposed to be zero um
so they're going to basically not apply
any steering angle they're just going to
break in a straight line
and um yeah the other thing we need to
specify is the human backup action set
you had h it's going to be very similar
except we give the human some leeway so
there's a range of possible
deceleration rates they can apply and
there's also a range of steering angles
that they can take
and yeah this forms the set of possible
actions
um so first i'm going to show some
results of our controller
uh in conjunct using our controller with
in conjunction with simulated social
forces humans
um and in this example you'll see that
the shielded aggressive controller
is going to cut in front of the human by
leveraging the fact that a responsible
human driver will
um apply a slight at least break
slightly
um to avoid a collision um
yeah so you see that the first blue car
there break to let the human pass safely
before continuing through the
intersection
and this shows that our our approach is
not overly conservative so
if it does compute that there's a way
for the human to slow down and avoid an
accident it is going it
can aggressively take the right of way
um assuming you use it with this
aggressive controller
um our second result is that the robot
is going to trigger
um kind of conversely if it can't
if it concludes that the human might not
be able to stop and avoid an accident
then it's actually going to trigger this
the shield is going to trigger and
override the aggressive policy
and um break to allow the human to pass
safely
so yeah here the robot in red as you can
see it comes to a stop before continuing
after the first blue car passes the
intersection
um and just to show that we have the
same kinds of results
i think this is the video i showed at
the beginning but now you can see that
in this case the this is a real human
driver
and um yeah they're going to pass the
there's this kind of complex negotiation
that goes on
and this is all kind of naturally falls
out of the shielding framework
so as soon as the robot is sure that the
human
um can come safely come to a stop it's
going to go ahead and take right away
and cross the intersection
uh in front of the human and because the
human is acting
their first order of concern is to avoid
an accident they'll actually stop and
let the robot go
um even though they also want it to
cross
our next example is um kind of again the
opposite where
the shield is triggered to let the human
cross safely so in this case the
human started closer to the intersection
closer to the intersection so they
passed first and then the robot breaks
slightly to allow the human to pass
um i said we also had um compared to an
npc
um it the mpc because it it can't
account for the fact that the human is
going to
might break in response to its actions
it's actually going to be more
conservative than the human
so it's going to slow down to let the
human pass
um even though it probably could have
crossed the intersection first if it had
been more aggressive
um and the next few experiments are just
to kind of demonstrate the flexibility
of our approach
um so first we have one oh sorry this
before we get there so this is first an
example with real humans where we
actually did have an accident
so here the human is acting aggressively
and it collides uh with the stationary
robot
so i'll show you what this looks like so
the human here didn't kind of break
quickly enough and they also steered
towards the robot um so
this shows that there are shortcomings
you know our approach doesn't
you know if the human drives in ways
that we don't anticipate there are
possibilities of accidents
happening um but it does at least
intuitively to me
it feels like it's somehow the human's
fault that they kind of drove towards
the robot and
didn't slow down quickly enough so there
when there are accidents it kind of does
match human intuition about who is at
fault in practice you
probably would want to fit the
some of the be more conservative in
terms of the parameters you set
um we set our parameters fairly
aggressively to show that you can get
this kind of
aggressive driving behavior
but if you wanted really wanted to
ensure safety you should set the
shielding parameters a bit more
conservative
um so the next two
[Music]
experiments just try to demonstrate the
flexibility of our approach so we can in
these cases we're going to modify the
backup action sets in various ways to
show that we can
get interesting new behaviors so first
here i'm going to show
an unprotected the robot executing an
unprotected left turn
um this is using the parameters that i
showed above
and as you can see there's this
undesirable behavior
where the shielded controller or where
our robot controller
it does safely come to a stop but it
stops in the middle of the intersection
which can confuse the human driver and
lead to congestion
and there's actually a pretty simple
modification we can make which is that
we can just add a constraint saying that
the backup policy is not allowed to come
to a stop
um uh in the middle of an intersection
so that doesn't count as safely coming
to a stop it has to either cross the
intersection or come to a stop before
the intersection
and as you can see here it's going to
choose to come to stop before
entering the inter entering the
intersection and it's going to wait for
the car to pass and then cross safely
and just as another example here we're
actually going to show that we can use a
just a totally different backup policy
where we pull over into the next lane
um so
as you can see when the um the human
driver kind of
pulls into the highway the robot merges
which is to the next lane in order to
avoid them
and this shows that you can use kind of
a variety of different backup policies
beyond the simple
slowing down to come to a stop and if
you are driving on a highway it
might actually not be safe to just come
to a stop in the middle of the highway
um which is why um so you might need to
consider different kinds of backup
actions
okay um so yeah just to conclude uh
so we've proposed a framework for
ensuring safety in the context of human
interactive control
where we start with a game theoretic
model of human behavior
and then we leverage
assumptions about human rationality in
conjunction with a
model predictive shielding algorithm to
ensure safety of the overall system
um and yeah so thank you all for
listening to my talk and i'm happy to
take any
remaining questions
thank you any questions so if you have a
question then you can
either raise your hand or just write
something in the chat and i can call
upon you um
[Music]
can i just ask yeah okay thanks us but
for a very nice talk um i have a
question so
you're saying that the showdown approach
and here intentionally you used it in a
very aggressive way
and in principle you can crank up some
thresholds and
the car will stop not right before the
intersection but
a little bit sooner than that for
example so that's possible is that
correct
yes that's right you can change the um i
mean there are various
i guess there's several parameters both
the robot backup policy
the human backup action set in that case
what we changed was
um what states are considered
equilibrium states yeah i guess i didn't
spell out exactly all the
parameters but we basically don't
consider the robot to really
be at a stop when they if they're in the
intersection that's not
that's not a state where the system is
at rest which
um yeah so you're not allowed to come to
a stop in the middle of the intersection
so
yeah there are these set of parameters
you can tune to
adjust the notion of safety
is there a way to consider also the cars
that are behind
the robot driver
in terms of their safety uh yeah that
yeah that's a i mean i mean you can
consider safety of the full
uh i mean the the framework is general
so you can consider safety of
human drivers behind um yeah i don't
think i have any experiments
to show along those lines but basically
the assumption this is why
we actually initially had the backup
action be to kind of break
sharply and then we did have some
examples where the
robot would get rear-ended so the the
backup action has to be constructed to
ensure that
uh humans both like driving
in the crossing direction as well as
driving behind the robot will be able to
anticipate and act safely
but assuming you design your backup
actions in such a way the
the framework can um will fork basically
the extension is just that it'll
forecast the behavior of
all the humans instead of just the one
human so if you have multiple humans it
just forecasts
all of them so then the assumption would
be that if the robot kind of breaks
gradually and comes to a stop then any
cars behind it will also break gradually
and
we'll be able to break gradually and
come to a stop as well without hitting
the road
just a one more question if i may there
have been a mod
there has been a model that i've seen um
i think in 2019
about the social behavior among this
robot so there was also a game
uh built on uh various rewards of the
of the robots not only taking into
account their egoistic
reward but also taking into account like
some social behavior somebody and can be
um altruistic or masochistic and so on
and so forth
so is it easy to also and and they were
also solving this tuckerberg game but
several step
stucco block is it also possible
to easily introduce this here this kind
of
game behavior right um
yeah so that would probably come into
play in terms of how the
optimal policy pi hat is designed so and
that's one thing i like about the
shielding approach is that you can
design a policy to kind of achieve
whatever behavior you want and then the
shielding
so it's kind of a modular system where
the shield is only responsible for
ensuring safety
um so i know there's been i'm not sure
i'm familiar with a specific paper
you're talking about but there's been
work using things like
different control algorithms and even
reinforcement learning to plan
in on these settings and you can so if
you have
such a planner you can use that to
generate pi hat
and then um once you have whatever pi
hat you just use it in conjunction with
our
algorithm to ensure safety um so
yeah that that's how i would kind of
structure that
okay so it's it's very modular that's
nice thanks
yeah yeah thank you for the great
question
in your setting you have really one kind
of human
if you started modeling some kind of
incomplete information where
let us say the human drivers come from
one of several different types you know
maybe aggressive drivers
uh conservative drivers and so on
then in some sense your the game solving
can become more complicated right
because
in a way you can try to predict the type
of the human while
doing your optimization
does your thing generalize to these
cases as well where
you know you get games of incomplete
information
yeah we haven't that's a good question
we haven't thought about that
specifically but i think
um i mean we've been kind of assuming
that you design the backup actions in a
way that they apply to all humans
and at least as a starting point i think
that's the right thing to do
but if you do observe that different
some human drivers
um drive more conservatively then you
might be able to tune their backup
action set over time
to account for that and still ensure
safety
um but yeah that's not yeah i think we
yeah we haven't accounted for this kind
of learn so certainly in pi
hat it like again it can be general and
it can it can
take into account these big these
behaviors
but if you wanted the shield itself to
actually adapt um i think it is possible
but that's not something we've done yet
okay thank you
are there any other questions
if not then let me thank ausbit again
on behalf of all the participants for
this wonderful talk
thank you and then uh uh we shall meet
again next
friday at the usual time and uh next
week mikhail siyana kakis
is the speaker okay
thank you everybody
thank you